hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the great
work okay so you guys told me that there
was a note here that needed to be read
before I could carry on so I'm gonna
read this note whatever it was that
attacked us left visible remnants of
itself everywhere there's no sign of
Maureen I can only hope that he escaped
unharmed expected the shards of the
broken stone here - but I've disappeared
as well not sure what to do from here
it's circled all it hurts the accident
during on expected regarding chemical
zoom:1 Maureen don't believe any story
they came up with that greatest strong
electrical source similar to the devices
in the myth Rambo hard stronger leg does
power my shard when the machine is
turning all the shards are enclosed most
able to do it a little brew harness is
synchronizer power and the processor
shard will recognize you doesn't grab
adores it each other the function is
intended the stone will be repaired it
will all be for naught if I can't locate
the other shards but I have to do
something about it Samuel Hart live okay
so the shard oh I might be able to
repair what I have of the orb with
Samuels device okay I still think that
Samuels a douchebag and then he is going
to betray me this is all an elaborate
ruse by Samuel he is really the secret
head of the order and is going to be an
[ __ ] that's what he's gonna do he's
going to be here we go you guys said it
and what whoa okay alright there we go
okay you guys said that something was
gonna happen if something happened there
we go and now I go into the basement
though the beasts obeyed simple commands
they weren't very bright easily confused
port in two directions
a few troublesome one had to be locked
in his chills above until he could
correct our behavior what he needed was
something a bit smarter something with
even a fraction of any intelligent like
me
alright buddy calm your tits there I
mean so far those statutes haven't done
anything to me I still don't like them
weighing on there's some obviously
behind here some some obviously or maybe
not maybe I'm an a-hole
it's all squishy and I still don't have
any oil so I'm still running on a high
gammer
trying to get by but I got nothing - who
there's some oil I'll save that for a
rainy day well wha oh no oh no you don't
I just had to freaking say something
about Oh d'Or oh those things those
tattoos haven't harmed me yet but now
sure is a good time for the ha ha giant
counts of goop blood where's this song
it's a ball I recognize this ball from
before hey look it's a sack of gunpowder
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you I
know I hang on it was right there
there we go wait that didn't work
oh I thought that was I need approach
charges stop goofing all over me it's
grody
[Music]
alright so some serious [ __ ] is going
down I gotta put this somewhere in the
middle maybe oh why is that thing fall
I'm a [ __ ] yo that's right [ __ ] off
Jesus it went away ah god damn it that's
got to stop
well okay so I got the shards here I'm
assuming I'm supposed to put them in the
pedestals
I guess hang on I got four that are free
wait no okay wait a minute wasn't there
another pedestal here I thought that was
another one right there
hang on maybe I got a grab and drag hi
thought so okay hop did it did it for
you
boom like a blouse all right so I got a
rod here and so this is a little the
machine is not powered up huh how about
you go F yourself let me go power it up
with my little ball here where is he was
he actually monster
oh damn it stop making noise ball stop
making noise I'm gonna put you right
here for safekeeping until I know what
to do with you oh how do I get away from
him how do I get away from I gotta go I
gotta go I gotta go
sorry sorry excuse me pardon me do me
pardon me I gotta go gotta go
got to get away it's giving me hiding up
here where you cannot see me I'm totally
in the darkness he'll never find me here
okay this is a bad hiding spot
where'd he go where'd he go where'd he
go he was here I saw him oh I see him in
the distance there he's walking the
other way let's not look at him now
let's get my ball need the ball need the
ball need the ball I don't know why I
need the ball but I need this ball it's
my ball you want to touch my ball
[ __ ] hell
yes pass pass pass ah piss damn it how
am I supposed to get around it means all
he's gonna be all day I'm gonna drop my
ball over there and I obviously okay
this is the Trinity steamer onto a
triangle up s I drop my ball okay I
dropped my ball I need my ball okay he's
going in a circle no mind me there you
go there you go okay is there something
under here that I need maybe some other
box with another rod you didn't see
anything you didn't see anything you
didn't see anything
rod rod rod rod rod rod ramrod come on
there's nothing in there are you kidding
me Oh piss he's gotta be over there he's
in here he's coming in here he's coming
this way
can't be here AHA there we go for face
that's a square one I finally learned my
amnesia lesson about a few years too
late okay so gotta get gotta kind of get
gonna get together get gotta go go go
ah pest Papa's gotta go away it's gotta
be here it's gotta be here somewhere and
the darkness
my face there's some in there behind
this goop no doesn't look like it I
don't see anything I'll stop I wasn't
even near the goop okay so that wasn't
anything here okay that's the wrong way
to go where is it should be here oh he's
coming just got to avoid her to her it's
gotta be some here that I'm missing you
didn't hear a thing Oh missed me dick
he's just wandering around I got to go
back and get my ball cuz I opted ass and
this is some here alright nothing
okay nothing okay where'd he go he's
gone oh no he's not gone he is right
there okay I just gotta go gotta go
can't be bothered by you need to go now
where the bloody hell is this thing
shouldn't it be right here ion I'm gonna
maybe I can find a way to get through
there through here put that there oh
come on
don't get stuck on me now like over here
maybe it's maybe it's maybe it's maybe I
don't think it's in there I don't think
it's in there I would not be the way
that it's going another let's go this
way
let's go this right now
[Applause]
okay super chase music you need to calm
down just a little bit I'm not anywhere
near where I need to be where the piss
is it where is it it should be here it's
not I've looked everywhere that there is
to look I looked in all of these I'll
see you all piss where the hell would it
be I've looked about everywhere why can
I not Pro dodge anymore I don't seem to
have completely lost my ability to
produce a second after I find it after I
find it haha hey stairs okay I'm an
idiot all right I've died multiple times
multiple times mostly because I was just
taunting the monster like poke around
and then he's like oh really and then he
smacks me in the dick all right so we
got all those we slam that in place okay
guy you calm down
[Applause]
my mind is tripping okay this guy seems
to be all about murdering me but he also
seems to be stuck so um I'm gonna Pro
dodge him like a mouse
come here buddy come over here hey come
over here he's stuck he's stuck man
let's just get out of here okay so this
did something to here so what was that
ah I got to turn this on furbish dress
oh hello
hey guy are we gonna assemble the or
bear
yeah he's dead that's another wall
that's coming out of my chest oh that's
not good oh look at that
and I bet in walks Samuel looking to
grab himself a brand new war
oh come on that's mine
how about you go screw yourself you go
to hell and you die I got nothing to say
why are you looking at me I don't know
what's going on
Hey look math and stuff you did yeah
sure that's what you think
yeah but you can't yeah but as long as I
have the shot they would never stop
hunting me uh-huh
and now it's gone yeah each step I take
is just what I do
interesting you know I have to do this
I've come this far already
I have to see through if I don't all of
my suffering was for nothing
now this is a noble guy you don't own
[ __ ] to Samuel who knows interesting
this guy seems to have noble intentions
but I highly doubt that Samuel does fam
you'll to dick and holy crap it looks
like my amnesia is crashing ah yeah my
amnesia crafts well that was a good time
to stop anyway ah but it's not gonna
save
oh well okay so anyway those are good
this time to stop as any I guess by that
sucks oh sorry about that my game
crashed and then everything else crashed
and then everything went to [ __ ] but I'm
back okay so I'm gonna try to finish it
all up in one episode in the next part
just to make it an even 20 because this
is the nineteenth part so thank you
everybody so much for watching I'm
actually kind of sad because this great
custom story is almost done cancelled a
dick punching party again
yeah sorry so click the annotations
which I finally got back working um
click the annotation for more videos
that I've done and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
[Music]
Hey
[Music]